j'accueille patrick devedjian
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais pas vous torturer avec l'assuré
vaut un bon c'est pas est ce que c'était
a ouais c'était pas à rouen 67
le mystère 360 c'est non non non bon il
s'était avancé alors j'allais que c'est
tout vous pensez vous dit finalement bon
il ya muraille du sympa on va pas se
disputer à la télé tout mais pour corser
un peu la faire j'ai demandé à mon ami
laurent baffie champions
[Applaudissements]
ça va très bien on n'a pas annoncé
pourquoi j'étais pas non c'est parce que
je voulais faire la surprise à patrick
devedjian connais pas et si on fait
complètement battant sur cinquante ans
que je sois là mais tout à fait j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un pour rebondir
comment ça va ça va très bien je vais
aussi je sais tout tu sais ton
par exemple est ce que tu sais que
patrick n'a jamais publié un livre
s'appelle penser la droite je les lui il
serait le genre de pensée la droite
voilà une bien écrit beaucoup de steve
j'ai passé un bon moment je déconne
c'est parce que je ne reconnaissais plus
ma fille principal adversaire s'appelle
delevoye vous intéresser un peu ça
bernard non il ya devedjian manager
certains concurrents voilà concurrents
il ya alliot marie il ya bulté qui et
ibéro maoïste c'est assez intéressant
comme un personnage à la musau par
celui-ci jean que manon pardon il est
gentil et sympathie à mais c'est devenu
notre copain musée hausse à lyon d'un
copain marseille maintenant il est sympa
mais quand on va à marseille nous ont
dors chez toi maintenant
bon alors delevoye lui il est soutenu il
est aidé par pandraud et pandraud pour
vous c'est tout ce qu'il faut plus faire
pendre au pont c'est la vieille-gare
quoi c'est une image un peu ancien du
rpr oui en moi je préfère avoir une
image plus moderne
j'aime bien [ __ ] difficile là c'est
pas dire déjà vous donner beaucoup de
mal tout seul mais c'est vrai que quand
on en rajoute encore j'adore bon et puis
en plus de le voir votre concurrent est
pas votre adversaire
il est sénateur parce qu'il n'a pas été
lu aux législatives et lui les sénateurs
il est peinard
et pendant ce temps vous vous collectez
l'assemblée nationale avec jose pas un
petit peu vrai c'est un petit peu est ce
que c'est un petit peu vrai par exemple
qu'elle entend que leur père a pas gagné
une ville dans le pas de calais ça c'est
un constat c'est un constat ils
s'adorent saint-benoît aïssa d'or c'est
un bonheur
sanaria s'est passée la fuite vers perth
[Musique]
oulala alors bien et ambiante le scrutin
et sur deux tours en principe et
delevoye il s'inquiète de qui va
s'occuper des urnes pendant pendant la
nuit du 1er jour de votre nom maintenant
il ya il sait sur un seul jour justement
à supprimer le deuxième jeu avant
problème ils ont confiance
ouais d'accord oui vous vous êtes dit
finalement si on fait tout en chantier
sur deux jours dans la nuit je veux dire
jusque là nous avions des candidats
uniques
oui alors ça posait pas beaucoup de
problèmes pour la première fois il ya
une vraie concurrence est vrai et si
plutôt bien oui alors ça suppose de
prendre plus de plus de précautions vous
savez quand on fait des élections
normales dans le pays aussi on prend des
précautions pourquoi on les prendrait
pas nous vous pensez pas qu'on a
l'impression que la droite finalement
ils sont plus préoccupés de se tirer des
baux entre que vous y à le battre que
battre logiquement je pense qu'ils sont
dans une situation que la gauche a connu
dans d'autres périodes donc je pense que
l'histoire l'histoire tourne mais je
crois qu'ils sont vraiment dans dans la
nasse et que là vous êtes dans un piège
pour pas mal d'années je crois je ne
crois pas parce que moi je crois que la
démocratie c'est une potion magique et
jusqu'à maintenant nous avons souffert
d'une insuffisance attendait d'entre eux
mais on se rattrape lundi de trouver la
bonne formule
non vous avez tous vous politiquement
parce que c'est ballot patrick devedjian
et et on va en parler mais a été très
violemment anti communiste attention
attirée anti stalinien
vous avez déclaré que vous deviez aucune
différence entre l'allemagne nazie la
russie soviétique et que c'est
maintenant avec les cadres du pc
aujourd'hui en france c'est exactement
pareil que les apparatchiks du rss vous
qui avez été vous avez été trotskiste
vous vous avez été au pc dans le sens
inverse d'abord au pc après 3 des 6 mai
oui et alors quand vous entendez ça je
parcours tout à fait conventionnelle je
suis je vais finir dans la peau d'un
vieux social-démocrate très peu
consensuel mais je n'ai rien renier de
ce qui a fondé
ma pensée quand j'avais 18 ans non cela
l'algérie c'est très vous êtes né en
algérie et la famille de votre mère
était algérie française fera une grosse
une partie voilà et vous vous êtes élevé
contre sens fait de prêter main
désistement l'arrêté mendésiste donc
c'est évidemment on était très ivre et
de faire l'indépendance de la tunisie
donc finalement vous êtes élevé contre
ça vous êtes j'étais pour l'algérie
indépendante
et vous alors ce qui vous a décidé à
entrer en politique c'est justement en
60 heures à condorcet d'algérie vous
pensez que l'algérie devait rester
française
absolument je pensais ça je pensais ça
parce que je suis aussi d'une famille
immigrée familles chrétiennes d'orient
et qui a vu sa liberté se réduire qui a
vu un génocide perpétré à l'encontre de
ce qui est et qui constitue en ligne
plaisir vous êtes d'origine va vous
habitez à votre famille habitait
constantinois parce que monsieur
devedjian le dis jamais istanbul 1 c'est
constantinople donc mais là c'était de
dire comme un villa située rue
donc monsieur devedjian votre famille
vient de constantinople et vous êtes
arménien donc vous dit que vous aviez
français oui d'accord bras d'origine
arménienne quand vous voyez mairie que
vous pleurez oui conviés à ce niveau
vous dit bonjour voilà donc vous avez
vous vous avez vu ce pouvoir confisqué
j'ai vu la montée de l'islam intolérante
j'ai vu ce qu'a été le nationalisme turc
ravagée justement la différence empêcher
les minorités d'exister et les supprimer
physiquement la guerre d'algérie c'était
pas la montée liste je me suis battu par
la montée de l'islam mais c'est bien
écouter ça a été ça en définitive
ouais enfin on peut raconter twitter
vous on prend sur 30 ans prend pas sur
dix ans la guerre d'algérie c'est pas
une guerre est une guerre d'un défaut
l'immense coloniale oui c'est pas elle a
monté de la mise je suis les frères
musulmans soient venus après longtemps
après mais c'est une autre histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une nation qui
s'appelle la nation algérienne c'est
plus l'histoire de l'amérique française
au delà du réel géré historiquement vous
avez parfaitement raison je me suis
trompé si c'est ce que vous voulez me
faire dire je vous le volant qui a aussi
une certaine manière mais le dit
volontiers comme disait nisand qui est
plus proche de vous j'avais 20 ans je
laisserai personne dire que c'est le
plus bel âge de la vie
mais donc je me suis trompé sur
l'algérie mais il n'empêche sur d'autres
choses mais oui mais bien sûr l'histoire
d'une vie c'est l'histoire de beaucoup
d'erreurs un bien alors si vous êtes élu
votre grande idée politique en fait
patrick devedjian s'il est élu patron du
rpr donc c'est de refaire l'alliance
c'est à dire de faire un grand parti
unique de l'opposition de saper votre
avis avant l'audi et c'est une de mes
idées mais sa maman j d on attendait ça
va marcher la première fois pour que
voulait recommencer je veux dire que ça
c'est incontournable de toute façon
c'est pas suffisant
c'est le nécessaire mais ce n'est pas le
suffisant ma grande idée c'est de
moderniser le rpr c'est d'en faire un
parti qui soit en phase avec la société
avec le monde tel qu'il est devenu
c'est vrai que c'est drôle ça
[Musique]
peut-être on fait tout ce que je voulais
mettre quoi je vais mettre autre chose
et je suis tombé votre campagne est un
peu désordonné on dit elle est un peu un
peu amateur pourquoi je n'ai pas
beaucoup d'argent
certainement j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
ce que je dis c'est le tueur né je n'ai
que la force de mes convictions c'est
déjà pas mal déjà beaucoup je lisais
l'autre jour on peut changer le monde
avec ses convictions et oui je lisais
l'autre jour que vous étiez dans une
voiture qu'elle été emmenés à la
fourrière du chalet dans le nord ça
arrive à tous les français car vous êtes
quand même un député
les bleus étaient périmés oui vous avez
plus de scène je l'échangé lors la
négligent vous êtes tombé en panne
d'essence dans tôt les faillites s'est
pas amusé part en couille la droite les
choses arrive à tout le monde c'est vrai
un truc normal croyait tellement que les
députés vivent dans un univers protégé
ben là vous découvrez un extrait de
carte bleue en question carte bleue et
panne d'essence on pense pas où ses
protégés c'est pour autre chose qu'on
pense qu'on en protège aimable pour le
relais en 97 le rpr a reçu 230 5
millions de francs alors vous qui vous
par personne vous qui vouliez pas
subventionner cliquer ou le pognon là
d'abord on paye un loyer qui est très
cher
deux centres c'est 215,5 millions jeudi
pour ma mère maman ça fait quoi 23
milliards de centimes a quand même un
nom peu c'est une belle boutique pendule
loyers le loyer non il n'ya pas que le
loyer mais faire vivre un milliard dit
ça coûte cher à faire vivre un grand
partisan m'attendais ou le podium quand
vous faites votre élection vous donne
quand même une allocation là pour votre
élection chaque la wii la wii nous
allons avoir cent trente mille francs
chacun cent trente mille francs chacun
seulement mais elle est où la différence
la différence d'abord le rpr c'est aussi
une centaine de personnes qui
travaillent pour lui qu'il faut payer
attendez ça coûte très cher je vous
adore phase où les 235 zambie ont
retrouvé les bras si je vous alliance
est pas bon si tu trouves pas ça louche
toi non c'est malheureusement pas
on connaît peut-être bien dépensé la
tournée des bars c'est vite parti
croyez moi c'est vite parti entend donc
certaines personnes ne sont prendre 5
millions ils sont 130 mille francs ils
sont six a fait un truc que les dix ans
900 mille pages tous les partis sont
dans cette situation c'est la démocratie
c'est normal c'est la république
syrienne est élu on attendait une droits
humains c'est parce que je dis un énorme
c'était soit étanche en panne d'essence
avec le blé tout appris t'aurais pu
quand même
non tu confonds une belle can il vous
mesurer combien à mettre 70 c'est à ça
tombe bien c'est ce qu'il a dit chirac à
sarkozy 1
il a dit je le vois lui valent c'est un
peu son candidat chirac un delevoye et
où c'est pourquoi parce qu'il mesure 1
mètre 90 ça c'est important
il même un peu plus je crois même un peu
plus fait 77 voulait que je suis un peu
juste en taille mais il
delevoye et plus haut il n'y a pas de
doute mais n'y aurait jamais pu être
président du rpr par exemple on peut
savoir pourquoi vous avez voté contre le
poste à huy facilement j'ai voté contre
le pacs parce que le remède est pire que
le mal
j'ai voté contre le panama les mama le
maintenant c'est un jeu de mots facile
charest à temps c'est facile ça peut
être
ouais plus subtile aussi max dont je
vais répondre à la question si un gros
lot on en attendait j'ai voté contre le
pacs parce qu'il institue une
discrimination nouvelle pour bénéficier
de nouveaux droits pour un homosexuel il
faut se déclarer et être inscrits sur un
registre accessibles au public et moi je
pense que la pratique sexuelle ça
appartient à la vie privée et qu'on ne
doit pas être obligé de la révéler pour
bénéficier de ses droits
c'est bête je ne vois pas comment on
peut être contre le fait que à un moment
donné des personnes librement qui
veulent s'associer et n'iront se
déclarer à la mairie que ceux qui
voudront c'est pas obligatoire quand
vous parlez de fichiers c'est un rapt
historique de 7 comme expression parce
qu'on voit très bien à quoi ça fait
allusion
donc c'est irrecevable dire comment
donné il va y avoir un fichier les
homosexuels non il ya un fichier de ceux
qui voudront un moment donné être pacsé
mais ceux qui n'ont pas envie c'est pas
leurs pratiques sexuelles qui va
abandonner les dénoncer s'ils vont pas
s'inscrire
les regarde non mais et en plus vous
réduisez d'abord le pacs à
l'homosexualité ce qui est pâle ce qui
est pas la réalité parce que c'est pas
que les homosexuels et deuxièmement vous
réduisez en parlant de l'homosexualité
l'homosexualité une pratique sexuelle
mais c'est faux il ya il ya une culture
homosexuelle existe donc on peut pas
réduire sa la pratique sexuelle dans
c'est pas simplement de savoir comment
les gens font l'amour qui valait
déterminé socialement donc il me semble
que comme sur l'europe moi j'ai voté
pour maastricht vous aussi on l'était
certainement pas d'accord sur le texte
il ya des tas de choses qui sont
imparfaites mais moment donné faut bien
passer à une étape supérieure
donc c'est comme sur l'avortement c'est
toujours l'arrière-garde il ya toujours
vous attend que c'est pour ça que en fin
de compte la droite reste ce qu'elle est
et que vous avez quand même pas rompu
avec vos origines c'est que à un moment
je parle politique
j'ai dit qu'il ya un moment donné ça
c'est pas c'est un combat d'arrière
garde
mais pas du tout je suis en train de
vous expliquer actuellement les
homosexuels qui par exemple vivent en
concubinage subissent une discrimination
inacceptable
il faut mettre un remède à cette
situation je suis d'accord la situation
actuelle n'est pas bonne
le remède proposé par les socialistes
c'est que les gens qui ne voudront plus
subir cette discrimination se déclare
par le pacs au tribunal d'instance sur
un registre accessible à tout le monde
et qui permettra de savoir quels sont
les moeurs qui sont choisis en moi je
dis cette chose on a le droit
on a le droit d'être homosexuel sans
avoir besoin de le déclarer publiquement
et je suis donc pour la protection du
secret de la timide accord n'ait pas
compris
marsh intellectuelle et présida ça c'est
une démarche qui part quand même de la
notion du bien et du mal
je vais tout votre raisonnement il parle
de la bernard murat bernard murat disait
patrick devedjian à l'instant finalement
vous n'avez pas tellement renier vos
origines alors politique politique bien
sûr c'est pas très bon c'est pas gentil
non messieurs les questions bien mais
c'est la goutte et il a été trotskiste
quand il est jeune âge et était
d'extrême droite voilà bon il ya 30 ans
qui sont passés c'est une vieille guerre
civile élite mois le front national en
92 vous avez déclaré tant que le front
national est légal il est légalisée qui
touche d'ailleurs ces fameux 40 millions
par an de l'état tant que le front
national est légal vous avez dit ça dans
le figaro c'est normal qu'ils puissent
se réunir et vous trouviez anormal à
l'époque donc en 92 que certaines
mairies interdisent au front national de
se réunir dans des salles municipales
en 98 vous dites le front national n'est
pas un parti républicain vous avez quand
même changé non mais pas du tout aussi
complet que le front national n'est pas
un parti républicain je souhaite son
interdiction pure et simple
oui dans le monde alors je vous pose une
question vous après vous répondrai est
ce que vous en faites pas un peu trop
pour faire oublier votre passé non je
vous explique très sain bon moi j'ai été
d'extrême droite je sais pourquoi je
serai obligé de prendre des positions
jour j mais je vous expliquais j'ai été
descendre jusqu'en 1966 en 1966 j'ai
rencontré raymond aron et c'est lui qui
a fait de moi un démocrate
quant à quant au front national je suis
le premier maire de droite
le premier en france à voir retirer sa
délégation à un de ses adjoints parce
qu'il était passé au front national donc
j'ai pas de leçons à recevoir
je dis simplement il faut être cohérent
si le front national est considérée
comme légale par les autorités de la
république
alors il a le droit à toutes les
libertés prévu par la république y
compris la liberté de réunion
ouais en revanche si on veut lui dénier
le droit de se réunir
peut-être faut-il considérer que c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas en réalité
réellement république a et qui menait
équipe dans ce cas là il doit être
interdit
repassez maintenant patrick devedjian à
une interview qui va être faite par
laurent baffie et alors on va voir si
vous êtes joueur
on bouge pas
[Musique]
j'ai pensé à faire une interview
dyslexiques tueuse un homme de droite
je vais poser des questions tu va me
répondre en tant qu'homme de gauche 1 et
allons-y dans l'excès répond moi en tant
que coco tu es un communiste alors que
penses tu des 35 heures si je suis
kabyle je suis pas dans le bon si tu
communiste qui commence t presse par
camara
c'est la base un élémentaire camarades
ma fille je suppose pourquoi parce que
je trouve même que 35 heures c'est trop
et je voudrais qu'il y en ait encore un
peu moins parce que le travail c'est
l'exploitation par le grand capital et
je n'ai pas envie de continuer la subit
l'impôt sur la fortune
je suis pour camarade baffie il est plus
dense que je suis pauvre et que ça
m'ennuie qu'il y en a qui soit riche et
donc je voudrais qu'on leur en prennent
à peu pour pouvoir améliorer ma vie
comme dans ses fidèles castro tu en
penses quoi fidel castro camarades il a
dévié mais hot rod au départ il était
vachement bien tu vois puisque il avait
compris les enseignements du camarade
lénine et puis petit à petit il a
vieilli et aujourd'hui camarades il faut
que tu saches que le vrai communisme
c'est différent de fidel castro en
politique aujourd'hui l'ennemi c'est qui
c'est la droite c'est la droite c'est
devedjian c'est le rpr
les joueurs savent pas quand on ne sait
pas quand tu sais que tu es très chiant
quand tu es sérieux et respect
mais cédé qu'en l'état la lumière
le président idéal pour 2002 c'est
robert hue mais c'est pas très réaliste
alors je voterai arlette laguiller le
concret avec c'est plus réaliste
c'est plus sympa tu vois il est en
correspondance avec les masses
populaires mais elle va mettre qui
oppose le premier ministre bat krivine
c'est idéal
et puis comme ça bernard murat on
retrouvera sa jeunesse à propos des
j'aime beaucoup
y'a pas que nous alors qu'ils avaient
sous tendance à quels sont tes chanteurs
préférés mais chanteur préféré
j'aimais beaucoup léo ferré et jacques
brel j'aurais pu dire aussi jean ferrat
leny escudero
oui j'aime beaucoup jean ferrat ou
acuppa c'était dernières vacances dans
le gers
moi j'avais au camping de melun meaux si
on devait débaptiser les champs-elysées
oui tu les appellerai comment toi fit
était au pouvoir la nuit car demain
enfin à oui c'est vrai j'ai oublié que
j'étais jeu là je l'appellerai avenue de
la victoire du prolétariat à ses biens
quels sont tes loisirs la littérature et
l'archéologie sapin petit atelier
banderole le dimanche
non et pour finir comment ils font pour
être aussi coin droite eh bien ils nous
imitent
et bien mais je sais pas parler
politique avec lui il est sympa mais il
faut mais il est chiant quand il parle
politique il vaut plus il dit pas où est
l'argent c'est n'importe quoi il dit
balladur est sympa que des conneries
quoi c'est pas lui qui a pris l'argent
c'est pas sapé comme ça je sais non mais
on continue alors cette fois je vais
vous mettre patrick devedjian dans les
mains de linda hardy attention il est à
vous l'une l'a d'abord mais à quelque
chose qui ont dû en échange vous
ressemblez à mr bean
par contre non non c'est non c'est juste
je sais pas je fais une comparaison
comme ça
par contre on peut dire votre âge oui 55
6 à 55 ans vous faites plus jeune que
votre âge vous êtes mariée à l'âge de 25
ans est ce qu'il y ait beaucoup d'autres
avant autres femmes en france qui n'a eu
d'autre oui beaucoup
combien
avant oui et n'est pas marié puceau quoi
personne coire et ça non mais bon ben
vous êtes de la droite
un homme deux pour les valeurs de la
famille on peut imaginer que ma tante
alors à quoi avez vous renoncé par amour
pour elle elle trouva pas assez de
choses en tous les cas ils pas à la
politique
oui je trouve que c'est pesant enfin
elle a accepté avec beaucoup de courage
mais elle trouve que c'est pesant donc à
vous êtes pas on peut lire elmed est là
d'autant plus de mérite du courage à sa
fiche
thales et sont arrivés mais le temps des
affiches c'est fini avant jean paul ii
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous
agace particulièrement chez vos deux
femmes et ce depuis 30 ans enfin depuis
sept mois et ce quelque chose qui fait
penser à moi oui oui oui bien sûr elles
ouvrent tout le temps les fenêtres
partout l arrivée elle ne ferme pas les
portes
alors ça fait des courants d'air et
samaoui ensemble comment tu comprends
d'après lui reversant oui mais voilà
est-ce que celle est devenu on se
réconcilie souvent sur l'oreiller tout
le monde tente tout le monde quand vous
avez l'impression qu'a fait une faute de
goût vous lui dites aussi ne pas se
rendre compte et comme on essaie voilà
elle trouve non je le trouve que je ne
payais elle trouve que ce ne suis pas
très bavarde dans ce genre de critique
et elle m'accuse d'être daltoniens
parfois en manie en matière d' harmonie
des couleurs ces biens l'avocat qui
parle je ne suis pas recevable dans ce
genre de petit commerce formé lui
téléphoner et pour lui dire quoi
deux ou trois fois par jour pour lui
dire quoi pour lui dire mais les
fouilles dirigées par mme c'est parfois
à ses subalternes je le reconnais moi ta
femme s'attaque aux asperges et après
les meetings vous l'appelez rendre vous
coucher il l'appelait oui tout le temps
tous les jours pas tous les jours mais
souvent quel genre de rapports vous
entretenez votre belle-mère d'excellents
rapports avec ma belle mère
le maire est adorable tu me disais
remporter ma belle mère est à doha puis
ce dimanche li qui débarque et sommes
les cas où ces modèles et l'amour hors
mariage vous a déjà tenté bien sûr
donc on imagine que vous avez beaucoup
de femmes que vous courent après je n'en
suis pas convaincu mais quand on voit
une jolie femme comme pou par exemple on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de l'admirer la
longue date à décrocher un petit boulot
de 56 ans patron du rappeur est ce que
vous faites dimanche matin en êtres de
généralement la grasse matinée
c'est peu traîne non avec une érection
paris pour 50 êtes vous seriez là mais
ce nom pour allumer la lumière merci
bonsoir je t'aime le cas de profession
et vous avez été pendant 20 ans l'avocat
de jacques chirac
bravo les jeunes est en taule en même
temps c'était un bon dossier
honnêtement c'était un bon dossier oui
un avocat qui commence ses phrases par
honnêtement ça peut choquer un vilain
appréciation alors ensuite j'ai été
ministre délégué aux libertés locales
c'est à dire quoi sa mini 5 réalisations
ah ouais à d'accord et puis ministre
délégué à l'industrie de 2004 2005 et l
arrivée de villepin thierry breton ne
vous veux pas comme ministre de
l'industrie vous refusez l'aménagement
du territoire qu'on vous propose
et vous devenez donc conseiller
politique de nicolas sarkozy
avec comme slogan à moi le ministère de
la parole voilà et c'est également le
titre du livre d'entretiens avec
emmanuel kessler journalistes à public
sénat la chaîne parlementaire que vous
publiez à l'archipel voilà alors en fait
les départs du gouvernement au moment de
l'arrivée de dominique de villepin
vous dites pour vous c'est un symbole
d'une politique de changement de cap
suite à l'échec du référendum mais en
fait c'est la même chose quoi je
raffarin ville pas c'est la continuité
quoi qui est quand même une volonté de
rattrapage ont perdu oui on a mis le
turbo
oui mais dans la même direction pour
vous villepin c'est le verbe
oui c'est pas mal de faire ben oui c'est
pas mal mais enfin par exemple quand il
dit cette année pas de petites phrases
vous vous dites effectivement villepin
ne fait pas de petites phrases il fait
des phrases creuses
je dis que quand on ne veut pas quand on
se plaint des petites phrases c'est
souvent qu'on aime les grandes phrases
creuses j'ai remarqué que dans cette
émission on aime bien les petites
phrases alors vous attaquez le bouquin
avec vos origines arméniennes votre père
est né là bas comme dirait doc gynéco
votre père d'or est arrivé en france à
l'âge de 18 ans ingénieur en fonderie et
il a inventé la cocotte-minute quand
même non mais n'a pas fait fortune mais
alors là non annoncés tels rival c'est
le concurrent
tu confonds avec le tout cuit
alors sur la turquie vous dites en tous
les cas qu'elle n'a toujours pas reconnu
le génocide arménien et qu'en turquie
c'est toujours un délit d' appeler ça un
génocide
donc vous êtes contre l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe voilà pas
seulement pour soi oui pas seulement
pour ça parce que pour vous c'est un peu
la turquie aujourd'hui c'est un peu
l'espagne de franco le portugal de celle
qu'elle n'est pas démocratique voilà
voilà c'est tout oui et puis suffisant
et puis à chypre hier chip ya chip qui
est partagé en deux et vous dites le
dernier mur de la honte en europe
il est à à nicosie ce que j -c que
l'armée turque occupe le territoire
européen
ouais et que peut pas faire entrer dans
l'union européenne un pays qui commence
par nous envoyer son armée
faudrait déjà qu'ils retirent leur armée
pour qu'on puisse discuter ça me paraît
raisonnable non ensuite vous expliquer
dans ce bouquin sur votre appartenance à
occident mouvement d'extrême droite dans
lequel il y avait alain madelin gérard
longuet alors vous dites gta occident en
fait pour défendre l'algérie française
face à l'époque à l'avancée de l'islam
et passe aux communistes il c'est toi
qui ferrer fait faire des erreurs à
nicolas aubé tu sais j'ai fait beaucoup
de conneries on m'a vu à l image des
mégalopoles
cette appartenance à occident alors bah
oui je me suis trompé j'ai déjà dit je
croyais à l'algérie française trouvé ça
patriotique comme j'étais un français de
fraîche date en plus j'avais envie de
donner des gages je me suis trompé
j'avais 20 ans je ne laisserai personne
dire que c'est le plus bel âge de la vie
lisant que oui je me suis totalement
trompé j'ai pas pris conscience à
l'époque du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes ansa ouais vous n'étiez pas
occident pour défendre la pureté de la
race quoi ben pour moi c'est difficile
parce que je suis déjà mélangé
alors dans ce livre vous n'êtes pas
tendre pour jean pierre raffarin vous
dit que c'était le règne de la
communication vous dites quand y avait
des séminaires à l'époque on abordait
jamais les questions de fond d'abord ont
trouvé le slogan et après on trouvait la
réforme qu'elle est avec lui je pense je
dis mon expérience et je dis ce que je
pense
pourtant vous étiez dans ce gouvernement
vous laisse je vais démissionner mais
j'en suis parti ouais vous on peut virer
quand même non on s'est pas entendus il
voulait me garder sur un strapontin et
ça me faisait mal aux fesses vous êtes
bien la lampre dire tout ce que vous
voulez là absolument
ça n'a pas de prix au sujet de chirac
vous dites il n'est pas de droite
dans tous les cas il ne se revendique
pas comme tel ouais ce qui est son droit
d'ailleurs
mais l'électorat de droite croit qu'il
est lui dans sa vie il ne s'est jamais
affirmer comme thème pierre lellouche
qui était assis là y'a quelques temps
disait que chirac était radical
socialiste rad-soc mais je crois qu'il a
raison
carrément jugement d'ailleurs il est
issu d'une terre radicale socialiste et
on est toujours marquée par son terroir
d'élections je crois qu'il a raison le
louche vous trouvez qu'il est rad soc
et en plus qui les démagos vous citer
une phrase dans votre bouquin en 94
chirac qui déclare je vous étonnerai
parma démagogie voyez nous a dit ça oui
pas seulement moi ont été très nombreux
à entendre cette phrase il nous a
effectivement étonné multisurf quoi sur
l'air du temps il est toujours d'accord
avec le truc du moment quoi il sait très
bien récupéré c'est une qualité
d'ailleurs pour un homme politique qui
sait très bien récupérer l'air du temps
c'est vrai que en 86 et j'ai fait moi
avec lui une campagne sur le printemps
libéral
faisait photographier en chemise ouais
non nous explique que ça se terminera
mal le libéralisme vous êtes sûr que
chirac va se représenter en 2007
non je dis simplement que il n'a renoncé
à rien jusqu'à la dernière seconde de
son mandat et que s'ils pouvaient le
ferai bien sûr il se représentait pas
sur la situation politique le lui
permettent ses pas su alors on dit
souvent que si chirac veut se
représenter 6 pour échapper aux
poursuites non ceux des blagues ça et
alors là par votre bouche nicolas
sarkozy lui dit que une fois son
immunité levée ne sera pas poursuivi non
je pense que c'est pas l'intérêt de la
france d'abord de s'amuser à poursuivre
ces présidents et qu'elle n'a jamais
fait parce que comme image
internationale c'est pas terrible
bon et ensuite je crois qu'il ya
d'autant moins de raisons de le faire
que tout ce qu'on a tenté contre lui
dans ce domaine a toujours échoué parce
que c'était pas établie et qu'on doit
fait quand même beaucoup de procès
d'intention avocats de chirac qui parle
quand même je pense que ici la gagner
c'est aussi parce que il était innocent
même si la ferme pas d'avocat qu'il
était d'abord innocent c'est juppé qui
après quoi alors que la rupture donc
d'être un partisan de sarkozy voilà il
faut il faut changer là il faut tout
changer
je pense que il faut un changement
profond et que par exemple le fait
d'être aussi habitué au chômage que nous
le sommes et d'un chômage très élevé
entre 9 et 10%
c'est à dire beaucoup plus que les eaux
il faut rompre avec ça le fait par
exemple est d'avoir un état très
dépensier l'état dépense 25% de plus
chaque année que ce qu'il encaisse la
personne peut résister à ce régime
il faut rompre avec ça voilà donc venir
le modèle social français en fait c'est
pas un modèle puisque personne veut
limiter à l'étranger bah oui un modèle
c'est quelque chose que quelqu'un a
limité le nôtre personne d'autre que
nous n'en veut et même nous on se pose
des questions c'est favorable au cpe la
trique de villepin contrat de première
embauche
je pense que ça pourrait
que c'est une mesure de flexibilité qui
peut créer des emplois qui doit créer
des emplois peut-être aussi on peut
l'améliorer en renforçant l'indemnité
des personnes licenciées
vous êtes libéral vous sur le plan
économique je suis libéral d'une manière
générale sur l'ensemble de la société
c'est à dire je suis aussi pour une plus
grande liberté dans la société
mais quand par exemple mittal veut
racheter arcelor c'est à dire quand le
plus grand aciériste mondial qui est
indien il aurait acheté un aciéristes
européens
oui le libéralisme ce serait de le
laisser faire normalement mais ça ne
m'indigne pains que mittal souhaite
acheter
lars eller je trouve pas ça scandaleux
d'ailleurs arcelor et était en train
d'acheter une entreprise canadienne au
moment où il a été attaqué par mittal
donc nous aussi nous faisons des opéras
donc on peut aussi en faire contre nous
ça ne me scandalise pas qui en est une
mais arcelor a aussi le droit de se
défendre oui mais pourquoi tout le monde
a parlé à ce moment-là de patriotisme
économique sur les dents le libéralisme
tout le monde a droit d'acheter tout le
monde mais moi ce que je crois être le
le patriotisme économique c'est
l'attractivité du territoire c'est
l'implantation de l'activité sur notre
territoire
maintenant la nationalité de
l'entreprise qui fait travailler les
français je crois que c'est accessoire
pourvu que ça se passe en france et
quand une entreprise française est
racheté par une entreprise étrangère le
risque c'est qu'elle s'en aille
oui ça c'est pas négligeable par exemple
quand toyota est installé à valenciennes
et créer 3000 emplois pour des français
c'est bien çà de là scandalise pas
pierre lellouche parle de syndrome
amélie poulain et vous de complexes
d'astérix choisir quoi c'est le déclin
quoi oui je suis un déclinologues comme
divine way juste battre ça se constate
je dire le rayonnement de la france dans
le monde
il s'affaiblit par exemple en 1998 la
france est passée derrière l'angleterre
comme puissance économique et l'année
dernière elle est passée derrière la
chine china grand pays mais enfin on
n'en finit pas de descendre les marches
de l'escalier on est combien on est
sixième à quand j'étais petit on était
4e ben voilà ça ça et ça va pas
s'arranger
pensez quoi tous ces jeunes qui veulent
quitter la france pour aller s'établir
en angleterre ou ailleurs les basses et
une interpellation pour nous dans les
années 50 les italiens s'en aller et
venue en france ce qui pouvait pas vivre
chez eux l'économie ne permettait pas
les espagnols les portugais mais
maintenant ils vivent pas trop mal chez
eux sains et il vous dira tout cas
personne s'en va et c'est chez nous que
ça se parle ya déjà une fuite des
capitaux depuis des années une fuite des
cerveaux en france depuis des années ça
se voit non
oui je crois que c'est ouvert merci pour
la recherche
yannick noah lui c'est pas pareil il dit
moi si sarkozy passe je me casse je
crois que c'est déjà fait nous ouais
j'ai déjà cassé cécilia sarkozy t'es sa
cellule york elle aussi mais leur venue
mais j'y tiens l'anniversaire de nicolas
qu'elle a organisé la wii c'est sympa
très vite christian clavier
écoutez je vais pas vous faire le compte
rendu de la soirée était d'abord une
soirée privée comme un article dans le
parisien bah oui a toujours des gens
pour les raconter ce qui se passe et les
questions clavier lui demanderais d'être
de droite vous tout dépend de ce que
vous mettez dans ce terme mais oui je
suis de droite
on va vérifier on va faire un droit de
test on va compter les points on va voir
d'accord est ce que christian clavier
votre ami je peux pas dire ça je ne
connais pas assez
oui il ya hockey ou pas écoute je ne
connais pas assez alors non à mais
j'aimerais bien ça vous choque
l'expression se débarrasser de la
racaille au karcher
non parce que c'est le langage qui est
employé dans les cités elle même un par
les gens des cités en fait c'est la
question que voulait demander tir et se
demandait s'il y avait le pen à cet
anniversaire
eh bien nous la réponse est non c'est à
choquer toit se débarrasser de la
racaille au karcher
je crois que nicolas est prêt pour faire
la prochaine campagne pour éléphant bleu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vous a choqué le retour des
couvre-feux oui c'est billy pas qu il la
désigne non j'aime pas ça 1
j'aime pas ça et je suis pas sûr même
que cette loi s'il avait été soumis au
conseil constitutionnel et de 1955
1 je suis pas sûr que le elle aurait
franchi le barrage du conseil
constitutionnel d'ailleurs nicolas n'a
pas employé pratiquement pas de manière
infinitésimale sérieusement vous pensez
pas qu'on était trop patient avec tous
ces gens là en banlieue non non on n'a
pas été trop patient ne pensais pas qu'à
trop d'immigrés en france
non j'en suis un moi-même pensais pas
qu'on était bien gentil quand même
jusqu'à maintenant
non je pense pas cela c'est difficile
l'intégration et il faut prendre du
temps et il faut de la patience
ne pensez pas que les chômeurs sont tous
des fainéants non je pense que le
chômage est une fatalité
vous aimez bien jean pierre pernaut je
ne connais pas je connais vous voyez
quand même la télé oui mais peu je
verrai son journal c'est pas mon c'est
pas mes oreilles les reportages sur le
sabot c'est bien je n'ai pas vu mais
pourrait bel ouvrage
les artisans en france lisf le supprimer
ou pas isf c'est ce qui détruit une
partie du capitalisme français le
résultat c'est que nos entreprises se
sont attrapés par le capitalisme
international
ça vous dirait de privatiser la sécurité
sociale je pense que c'est pas à l'ordre
du jour n'a pas beaucoup de sens vous
avez acheté des actions d'edf nom de
karcher
ça monte car c'est vrai est-ce que vous
pensez que nicolas sarkozy est plutôt
belle sommes quand même il faut demander
aux femmes ce ne sais pas ce qui m'a
attiré chez lui en tous les cas vous en
pensez quoi
c'est pas le sujet entre ça peut aider
en politique le général boulanger l'été
bel homme oui mais ça c'est mal qu'un
char était pas mal non plus raymond
barre et non génial vraiment bas
villepin est assez bel homme oui pas et
il parait t'il dit pas paraît t il enfin
vous voyez bien quand même à ilan saint
nicolas non mais je vous dis simplement
c'est aux femmes de porter un jugement
le jugement des hommes sur les autres
hommes est généralement faux vous
trouvez que ça fait [ __ ] non pas du tout
jeux cij
j'ai adoré sont nombreuses et au
bien-être anglais
vous voyez là c'est exactement comme
histoire du karcher c'est avec une
réponse à une question
quand vous condamnent vous avez combien
d'albums de michel sardou chez vous j'en
ai pas je sais pas si vous êtes de
droite finalement c'est plutôt léo ferré
et moi ouais à aulas la ola ouais bah je
servirai de l'ump anarchie vous aimez
les hommes avec des mocassins à glands
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir des
mocassins pour être à gland vd
j'accouchais qu'une blacks
non vous pleuré en entendant la
marseillaise non est ce que vous pouvez
trouver cinq éléments positifs dans le
bilan de jacques chirac
oui bien sûr oui par exemple je trouve
très bien la déclaration de jacques
chirac sur l' esclavage troyen je trouve
très bien
la déclaration que jacques chirac avait
fait sur la rafle du vel d'hiv très bien
en 95 formidable très bien on aiderait
bâle 2-2 je trouve très bien la position
qu'il a pris sur maastricht oui mais il
a permis que ça passe alors que s'il
avait fait la politique du pire peu
c'est vrai on aurait échoué
bon on peut rajouter l'irak il a refusé
de faire la guerre avec les américains
quand ils n'étaient pas là il est en
vacances à l'heure n'est pas encore à
quoi vous faisiez vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis d'accord avec ces biens se
fait quatre oui donc plus qu'une jeu il
a il a été favorable aux des
nationalisations
dès 1986 et il a eu raison parce que
c'était le sens de l'économie mondiale
trouvez normal vous qu'on vendra
quelqu'un qui appartient à tout le monde
qu'est-ce qui appartient toujours pas
quand on a privatisé tf1 oui a vendu à
monsieur bouygues
mais il ya eu de l'argent est reparti
les oules argent mais il est dans les
caisses de l'état
ça a été souvent et les tailles
l'affiché en l'air mais c'est quand même
pas de la faute
c'est les français qui avaient payé tf1
c'est les français les 20 jours en
turquie c'est le pari est vendue au bon
prix on dit toujours ça quand on a vendu
quand on a vendu on dit toujours que
c'est on a besoin du passé chez réalités
propres des vendeurs de trouver qui
n'ont pas vendu assez cher vous avez
déjà rêvé érotiquement de villepin et
l'aidera s'en souviennent est ce que
vous trouvez qu'ils aient assez de flics
en france oui y'en a assez gauche ou
droit comme un i vé il est à 3 contre 17
vous trouvez que la france va mieux
depuis 2002 elle va mieux qu'avant 2002
ah oui en quoi par exemple à notre
économie c'est davantage dynamiser que
ne l'était à ce moment là non
sérieusement je pense et je peux aussi
vous faire un long discours pour vous
l'expliquer mais je le pense et un
déficit colossal on est dans la course
et 20000 euros par personne a compilé
nouveau déficit le déficit on leur haine
depuis 1981 c'est pas ma raison ça s'est
accumulé cinq ans c'est pas moi c'est
l'autre
alors qu'avant c'était un petit d'accord
mais bon vous avez été là voilà oui on a
pas on n'a pas redressé la france en
quatre ans ça c'est sûr
comment il faut de temps pour redresser
la france bon jeu mais il faut surtout
peut-être beaucoup d'énergie ouais c'est
la raison pour laquelle je soutiens
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup
[Musique]
gagnent des parts à lanoraie j'en gagne
voilà là écoutez oui non mais on
réfléchit nous on va aller voter en deux
étapes gynéco au ministère de la culture
voit pas mais j'ai passé on a vraiment
envie qui va pas au bureau le matin
trop sage pour ça est-ce que vous pensez
que seuls les plus forts sont sortiront
et que c'est très bien comme ça
d'abord je pense que les plus forts ne
s'en sortiront pas nécessairement tout
seul et c'est pas très bien comme ça je
ne crois pas la loi du plus fort
pensez pas qu'il faudrait interdire le
cannabis mais il est interdit
oui c'est vrai
la raison c'est un gars lui c'est
marrant parce qu'on on zappe pas chaque
fois faudrait prendre l interdire encore
plus nombreux mais je crois au contraire
ça et c'est correctionnalisé rien
aujourd'hui
moi je suis plutôt partisan d'en faire
une amende et le taux du crédit on peut
le bc pour les gens qui n'ont que très
peu d'argent pour acheter du cannabis
toujours il ya d'ailleurs en ce moment
un projet
deux banques spéciale pour
les gens en difficulté qui est une qui
est une qui est une banque d'un à
caractère social très particulier et qui
sera subventionné par l'état mais génial
at enthousiaste là est ce que vous êtes
contre le mariage des homosexuels
donc ça ne me scandalise pas vous êtes
contre l'adoption d'enfants par les
couples gays ou lesbiens ça ne me
scandalise pas ah ouais ça nous pourrons
contre je suis pour la liberté et je
vais vous dire une chose dont on n'a pas
assez pris conscience c'est déjà
possible parce que premièrement
l'adoption par un célibataire est
permise par la loi c'est une loi de 1994
donc faites par la droite et
deuxièmement le conseil d'état jugé
depuis longtemps que refuser l'adoption
d'un enfant sous le prétexte que
l'adoptant est homosexuel et illégale
donc l'adoption des enfants par les
homosexuels c'est déjà bien hays
l'effort vous faites toujours avocats
non mais je prendrais bien beau les
achats si vous êtes favorable à la peine
de mort dans certains cas n'a alors
jamais très précieux suis abolitionniste
les lycéens enfants je suis
abolitionnistes j'ai toujours été
abolitionniste ceux qui piratent de la
musique sur internet
quelque chose est ce que vous êtes
heureux qu'on retrouve bientôt le pauvre
alain juppé bien sûr je pense que comme
vous l'avez d'ailleurs suggéré tout à
l'heure que la peine
qu'il a subi il pas nécessairement
équitable etc dans tous les cas ce sera
bien pour lui quand ça se termine
j'aurais pas que le smic ça pénalise un
peu la reprise économique quand même le
smic c'est surtout indispensable pour
vivre
pensez pas que les français sont une
population d'assistés quand même non je
pense que le système le modèle social
est mauvais voilà et qu' il n'ya pas
d'incitation à l'effort mais assister
les gens quand ils sont en difficulté
pour qu'ils surmontent leurs difficultés
et pour les encourager à faire des
efforts ce support ça vous énerve les
jeunes qui portent des tee shirts
guevara n'ont donc pas du tout non j'ai
fait suffisamment de conneries étant
jeune pour une pâle est reproché au
jeune marin 8 à 25 ans vous êtes de
gauche d'extrême gauche ma carte judas
vous devez écrié l'ump c'est de la merde
eh ben je ne fais pas je le fais pas
parce que je le pense pas bon une autre
carte alors qu'arte suicide
vous devez déchiré cette photo de
nicolas sarkozy
je la vois parole à la fête ont pas
besoin d'apporter ça c'est possible
ah oui parce qu'il y en a beaucoup ça va
passer sa vie
[Musique]
c'est pour ça je ne sais pas
monsieur alors bon soir patrick je vous
ai invité ce soir pour vous permettre de
revoir christophe alévêque
en effet vous êtes connu lors de
l'émission de laurent ruquier on a tout
essayé
à l'occasion de la sortie de votre livre
à moi le ministère de la parole à
l'archipel dont nous avions également
parlé ici alors pendant l'émission de
laurent ruquier
christophe alévêque avait déploré que
vous ne fassiez pas mention dans votre
livre du bilan de nicolas sarkozy dont
vous êtes le conseiller politique rien
sur la violence rien sur la délinquance
et vous aviez pris mutuellement
l'engagement à ce moment-là de vous
revoir
eh ben c'est ce soir voilà c'est ce soir
plus exactement
christophe alévêque avait dit que les
statistiques étaient fausses truqués
étaient truquées et à manipuler way et
donc j'avais dit que je revoyais on met
formellement là j'aurai le bilan mauvais
parce que c'est compliqué à tanger fut
une enquête alors je précise moi je ne
suis ni journaliste ni homme politique
je suis un clown un mais comme on avait
pris l'engagement de faire ça y'a pas
que les hommes politiques ont le droit
de dire des conneries moi aussi
d'ailleurs vous êtes digne de ce point
de vue là de faire de la politique
tout à fait la culture du résultat mais
c'est pour ça que je veux parler du
bilan de ce cher monsieur sarkozy que le
monde entier nous envie surtout l'iran
et
c'est que il lui pour pour test de
départ la culture du résultat mais pour
arriver au résultat il est capable de
tout et n'importe quoi donc déjà vouloir
démontrer oui oui je vais essayer de je
vais essayer de le faire donc content il
dit baisse générale de la délinquance
déjà c'est fou mais il ya quand même des
chiffres indéniable par exemple il ya
quand même 40 mille voitures qui ont
brûlé en 2005 un sas et on est dans le
guinness des records
1 110 par jour ça fait quand même vous
avez quand même relancer le marché de
l'automobile avec sa est une
augmentation des violences ça vous
n'avez pas pu non plus donc 7 % de
novembre 2004 à novembre 2005 quand même
énorme gigantesque et là vous ne pouvez
pas tricher sur ces chiffres là parce
que sont sondés des plaintes qui ont été
vraiment déposé quoique on peut encore
tricher là-dessus à mon avis vous l'avez
fait et je vais citer un exemple pendant
la crise du cpe par exemple j'ai pas si
vous souvenez j'ai cette jeune femme qui
s'est fait agresser aux invalides
elle a eu chance à elle sa photo dans
paris match et bien la première fois
qu'elle est allée porter plainte au
commissariat on lui a refusé sa plainte
pourquoi parce que moins il ya de
plaintes à moins de chiffres elle a été
blackboulé carrément seulement comme
elle a eu sa photo dans paris match
après évidemment la plainte a été prise
6 si ça n'avait pas été le cas venu
alors elle est revenue oui bien sûr mais
vous pensez que le le fait de lui
refuser sa plainte de la première phase
est normal mais je vais m'expliquer là
dessus faites tout de suite non mais je
vous laisse aller jusqu'au bout de votre
démonstration je veux pas vous
interrompre d'accord alors il est gentil
un brutus alors
tu quoque oui mais je dis brutus parce
qu'il a quand même tué chirac dans son
livre donc quand on perd il va bien
oui eh bien oui c'est nous qui allons
mal alors
[Rires]
voilà donc ça c'est un exemplaire d'un
exemple mais il y en a plein d'abord
signalé que la droite a eu la belle idée
de supprimer la police de proximité
on a vu le résultat ouais si vous avez
supprimé la menace n'est pas un problème
de proximité donc ça fait moins beaucoup
moins de plaintes étant donnée quant à
quelqu'un à côté de toi évidemment tu
vas plus tendance à apporter plein fouet
plus facilement alors pour les dépôts de
plaintes voilà comment ça se passe j'ai
vu pas mal de gens et j'ai vu ou eu
beaucoup de policiers donc c'est eux qui
m'ont dit tous les mois la police je la
crois
alors il ya digérer bien il ya des
ordres oro est à moi je respecte la
police monsieur heures sauf quand
tellement merde alors il ya des ordres
or on est souvent oraux et écrits 1 on
dit aux policiers on les incite à ne pas
prendre de plainte c'est à dire poussé
le plaignant a déposé ce qui s'appelle
une main courante
hélas si les les plaignants tous les
plaignants avaient vraiment déposer des
plaintes ce qui doit également est
légalement et le cas les statistiques
auraient explosé il ya quelques chiffres
ici que je peux vous citer par exemple
cite une enquête donc de l'insee qui
avait fait enquête de victimation de
l'insee près d'un quart des vols et
tentatives de vols ont été déposées en
mains courantes et non pas en plein
temps normal près d'un tiers des
violences physiques c'est palin c'est ça
c'est l'inspection générale qui est ni
celle là non non non c'est le sait le
l'insee mais c'est comme si un organisme
indépendant évidemment ça ne nous
arrange pas et près d'un quart des vols
avec violence
ce qui nous fait mais un paquet de fait
qui ne rentrent pas dans les
statistiques donc qui sont en mains
courantes
on leur conseille aussi aux jambes au
cou de d'écrire au procureur de la
république ce qui ne sert absolument
strictement à rien mais comme ça on
évacue la plainte ou à laon requalifie
la plainte
par exemple une voiture brûlée au
requalifie ça en atteintes aux biens
c'est à dire quand il ya trop dans un
vase on met dans un autre vase
ensuite il est passé on va bosser mais
il est laborieux le peuple s'adressent
ces gouvernants oui c'est vrai que le
peuple sait pas très bien faire mais il
faut laisser le peuple s'exprimer mais
il a le droit de s'exprimer c'est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs mais je trouve un peu à
ça mais bon ok mais oui voilà cet aspect
précis puis le peuple et laborieux
heureusement je râle pas le contraire il
joue plus vite alors et couture sinon
alors ben on va quand on a fait le cpe
on est tout petit il a maintenant alors
on est une personne au lieu de trois par
exemple dans les accueils dans les
commissariats ce qu'avec ça fait des
files d'attentes pas possible par
exemple on transforme les délits les
délits qui sont des délits qui rentre
dans les statistiques par mille astuces
possibles en contravention car tout ce
qui n'est pas crimes et délits
n'apparaît pas dans les statistiques
à la fin il ya aussi le guichet unique a
été mis en place
guichet unique c'est à dire que par
exemple tu peux déposer plainte à
marseille pour un truc qui était arrivé
à paris
donc le temps que ça fasse le chemin
évidemment en chemin il ya pas mal de
plaine qui disent ont dû sauter sont
évaporés voilà et il ya donc une
différence à peu près de 5% entre les
enquêtes de victimation qui ont été
faites par un organisme indépendant et
les statistiques fournies par le
ministère de l'intérieur
donc où sont passés ces 5% alors patrick
bini n'ont pas fini allez-y locaux qui
bieber est bon mais moi je suis d'accord
pour qu'il vide son sac parce que trois
sont tous à part d'une grossière erreur
de base alors je laisse s'enferrer dans
l'erreur de base d'un an en gros ce que
dit celle-là parce que dira compris ce
qui se dit christophe on a tous compris
sa tactique sont truquées voilà c'est
d'accord mais on met pas les plane dans
les plinthes voilà on fait des mesures
qui rempile à mille facettes et 600000
astuces mali voila voila c'est ce qui
fut voilà voilà
et c'est bien organisé et tout ça sous
couvert d'un organisme de qui s'appelle
donc
un territoire national de la délinquance
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance créé par nicolas sarkozy qui
lui-même nomme le président donc c'est
vous dire l'objectivité les organismes
bon président là bas et qui chf
c'est monsieur bah ouais oui c'est à
dire un militant socialiste
j'aimerais bien sûr cinq militants
socialistes oui c'est chez lui à main à
l'accord
alain bauer il était au cabinet de
michel rocard oui il le déclare lui même
c'est pas qu'il accusait un militant
socialiste mais c'est un honnête homme
oui tout à fait mais surtout tous les
gens dont je parle sont des zones et
hommes alors on va essayer d'expliquer
comment ça marche
voilà reste dans lequel nous les
statistiques criminelles et délinquante
en france elles ont été réorganisées sur
initiative de monsieur jospin en 2001
pour avoir des statistiques qui soit
plus contestée par les gauchistes
impénitent et donc on a créé je ne sais
pas faire grimper mais georges vous
pourquoi vous sentez visé
voilà puis d'avoir ce n'est pas une
maladie non ça se guérit très bien mais
avec l'âge de lier et l'argent dans des
cas extrêmes droites bel et bien voilà
bien quarante ans que vous êtes guéri
mort mais oui complètement mois avant
aidons donc l'observatoire national de
la délinquance est un organisme
indépendant ce n'est pas le ministère de
l'intérieur
il a été créé oui excusez moi ça fait
rire d'accord mais s'il suffit pas de
rire il faut aussi le démontrer il est
doté je viens de vous dire qu'il est
écrit mise en cause il eu le chef est
nommé par sarkozy et tous les genres y
sont alarmés des monsieur amédée les
visionnaires gens nommés par le
gouvernement
ça c'est pas une nouvelle vous n'avez
pas découvert grand chose cela dit un
conseil d'orientation qui contrôle tout
l'appareil des statistiques et qui est
formé de personnalités indépendantes et
présidée par monsieur alain bauer qui
est un grand spécialiste de la
criminologie qui quitte un expert et qui
donne d'autre part quelqu'un qui se
déclarent de gauche et c'est bien son
droit
donc ces statistiques sont analysés très
sérieusement alors vous dit
il ya une différence et c'est vrai et ça
c'est près avec les enquêtes de
victimation qui sont faites par le cnrs
et par un organe indépendant mais il ya
une différence
naturellement importante même entre les
enquêtes de victimation et le
recensement des infractions commises
c'est parce que sa part de 2 démarche
complètement différente
les honnêtes et l'autre malhonnête si
vous voulez me le dire comme ça
le lait on essaye de recenser et je veux
dire là vous êtes en train de vous faire
un blabla impossible attendait cela
impossible me laisser répondre où vous
voulez rejoindre mais là je vous vous
dites c c c c c java qu'il était normal
que je vous dis non c'est pas normal
messi blessé parce que vous n'y
comprenez rien mais je vais vous
expérience est sûre je vais vous
expliquer c'est son métier
oui mais c'est pas si villa métier que
ça d'être avocat vous savez c'est pas
non plus un vilain métier parce que ça
vient mais là où il n'y a pas d'homme
politique n'y a pas de démocratie ça
dépend comment il va transférer
peut-être origine dans lequel n'y a pas
d'homme politique
nous non pas tout non mais je prends ce
poêle je les ai donnés dans lequel dans
les chiffres par exemple ces clichés
sandell sont pas truquées mais les chefs
ne sont pas truquées mais nous dit je
vais essayer de vous expliquer pourquoi
ils ne le sont pas et vous voulez pas
m'entendre je comprends que ça vous
dérange donc il ya d'un côté le
recensement dans tous les commissariats
de france des aidants tout les postes de
gendarmerie des infractions commises
il y as parfaitement vous avez raison
une distinction entre les plaintes
reçues et la main courante et certaines
déclarations vont sur la main courante
d'autres vont sur les plates et on peut
il s'est parfois on s'en est plaint
avoir une différence entre les deux
c'est exact mais l'office a menacé hier
sa différence qui légitime et chérie
fais référence j'essaie de vous
l'expliquer ben on l'observé policiers
incitent à l'est les plaignants a déposé
des mains courantes gens se déplacent
que des plus arriver ça peut arriver et
chaque fois que ça a été signalée ça
peut arriver souvent non je vais vous
expliquer chaque fois que ça a été
signalée au ministère de l'intérieur
d'abord il ya une enquête des services
chaque fois deuxièmement ça n'a pas
d'importance parce que de toute façon
l'observatoire national
la délinquance il recense toutes les
mains courantes et toutes les plate est
donc l'un d'eux son public donc que ça
soit sur l'ain où que ce soit sur
l'autre ça n'a pas d'importance
on a le tout premièrement deuxièmement
d'ajouter à la salle d'engager des
livres qu'on annonce sont les chiffres
des plans jeu terme si on rajoute nous
on accorde les jeux asiatiques explose
au trône et internet est ce que je viens
voter ce soir en temps chez vous prenez
internet taper jeu des jabots servent à
thouars observatoire national de la
délinquance et vous aurez les
statistiques pour le mois de juin et
vous verrez et vous verrez que les
statistiques pour le mois de mars
contiennent également les mains cours
donc j'en viens là contre rené vous
comprenez ce que je viens de vous dire
d'or
non mais tout le monde comprend chelet
attendait jeu je le sais ça mais quand
on présente les camps le ministère de
l'intérieur présente ces chiffres ils ne
présentent pas les désigner pas au
courant tout non c'est faux mais si tout
est fait pour voir une troisième fois je
t'ai jamais ce jeu mais c'est faux c'est
que tout est permis pour les personnes
gentiment tout le monde peut le vérifier
sur internet
deuxièmement les enquêtes de victimation
c'est une toute autre démarche faite par
le cnrs
chez les victimes elles-mêmes comme
c'est effectivement assez difficile de
d'avoir une exactitude certaine en
matière de recensement le cnrs faire une
haie qu'une étude auprès des victimes et
leur demande par mode de sondage
l'année dernière on a sondé 20000
personnes comme ça vingt mille victimes
et leur demande alors ce qu'il ya des
gens aussi qui subissent des infractions
et qui ne vont même pas déposé plainte
ni même de faire de ma courant parce
qu'il n'éprouve pas le besoin déposé
plâtre les les bagarres entre
automobilistes par exemple ou des
violences conjugales souvent les gens ne
vont pas déposer plainte ni protester
donc les enquêtes de victimation
établissent des infractions qui ne sont
pas déclarés elles sont publiées
également et il ya évidemment un écart
et cet écart
il est constant c'est à dire que le cnrs
que vous aimez ce temps parce que si
vous avez raison c'est un organe
indépendant il a constaté que la
régularité des recensements par rapport
aux enquêtes de victimation était
homogène et rendait impossible toute rus
kat
voilà bien alors vous ce que vous dites
en fait c'est que depuis que sarkozy est
là la violence et la délinquance ont
baissé
non mais attendez pour la peau ce qui
concerne les statistiques et la gauche
et la droite ont oeuvré ensemble avant
après ensemble pour essayer d'avoir un
appareil statistique fiable parce que ça
toujours donné lieu sous tous les
gouvernements de la part de toutes les
oppositions à des contestations dont
qu'ils ont essayé d'avoir un appareil à
peu près indiscutable avec ces deux
méthodes statistiques qui ont été
établies encore une fois deux concerts
par la gauche et par la droite
on constate que la délinquance
globalement ça c'est vrai c'est
globalement il ya des secteurs dans
lesquels elle a augmenté globalement abc
faux 8,2 pour cent de même que de même
que l'élucidation aux avis que c'est
l'élucidation des faits s'ils ont bien
passé de 26% à 36 % à l'élucidation il
ya des bizarreries aussi qui se passe là
dedans c'est jav qui va devenir un
spécialiste sur l'échiquier par exemple
un chéquier volé ouais bon chéquiers
volés et le mec fait des chèques et
signe avec son sa signature ouais comme
ça bon il fait tout le chéquier ouais
bon on retrouve un chèque on retrouve le
mec
ouais voilà et ben en fait ça va compter
à chaque fois le lot à chaque check et à
chaque choc est une fille cette dation
donc t'as un mec et 50 élucidation oui
mais attendez
elle est pas belle la vie donc là c'est
dieu ça te fait
mais ça je trouve bien je suis là je
trouve plus à une vraie démarche
citoyenne si je peux les vaches mais si
je peux lui répondent oui je lui dirai
que cette méthode qui peut être
contestée je le veux bien a toujours été
la même elle n'a pas changé
donc quand les lunettes quand l'élu
citation progresser ça correspond à
quelque chose à l'intérieur je me suis
renseigné
effectivement tous les chiffres ont été
plus ou moins truquées dans les
ministères de l'intérieur
mais là on a atteint 1 on atteint un
sommet c'est ce que tout ce que vous
avez trouvé pour expliquer que la
délinquance est baissé mais moi je vais
vous dire jouer en corse n'a pas baissé
pas assez elle n'a alors c'est au plus
alors il ya un autre truc en plus donc
le paradoxe quand même c'est que les
effectifs de la police ont énormément
augmenté inde après donc le nicolas
sarkozy 7823 missionnaire vous avez
évolué dans taux augmenter en peluche
assure depuis 2002 alors comment se
fait-il qu'un avec plus de policiers ça
n'est pas chuter beaucoup moins que fait
la police
elle l'a fait vous savez par exemple
lorsque vous mettez de la police parce
qu'ils en voient reconnaître le train
elle n'avait pas avant mais rien n'avait
pas à monsieur c'est le mot route cher
quand même tous à vimy fonctionnaires en
plus mais sans fondement écrit de cinq
heures parce que mais au moins on fait
des apparitions ces primes pour les
transferts résultat les primes aux
résultats aux résultats et je peux dire
qu'un commissariat qui fait pas ses
chiffres au niveau de la délinquance
ça barde 1 alors pour faire les chiffres
qu'est ce qu'on fait je croyais qu'il
laissait oran on rend une copie
on rend une copie par des jeux croyez
qu'ils les sous-estimé alors là vous
voyez vous êtes en contradiction avec
vous même
non parce que vous nous avez si les
quais tout via leur pub est sous-estimé
maintenant vous nous dites qu'il faut du
résultat donc il nous faut des résultats
il faut du chiffre mais non c'est
contradictoire mais c'est pas du tout on
peut avoir moins de délais non seulement
c'est pas content non seulement les
chiffres de la délinquance des la
violence n'ont pas baissé mais en plus
en embauchant huit mille fonctionnaires
de plus il aurait dû naturellement même
sans truquer les chiffres il aurait dû
naturellement baisser encore plus c'est
à dire si on considère vos chiffres
avouent qu'ils sont faux normalement ils
devraient être encore beaucoup plus bas
c'est normal avec 8000 fiq de plus mais
vous savez normalement dans la société
avec jeu se passe a augmenté de 16% mais
moi
avant le parti se tient en même temps
avec jospin avaient augmenté de 16%
augmenté l'aca a baissé de 8 films qui
sont balancés comme ça c'est là c'est la
housse avec europe ce que vous va lancer
les chiffres de jospin qui ne veulent
rien dirent 16% si c'est juste une chose
qu'on n'a pas le lien c'est sûr que
monsieur vaillant jeu l'accès à tous ces
chiffres ne veulent absolument pas ce
qu'on veut en nourriture dans les
chiffres conclusions dérangent
quand coach georges ont dit qu'ils sont
faits les chiffres ne dérange pas
conclusion le bilan de monsieur sarkozy
est nul mais les français ne sont pas
convaincus lé voilà ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'ils en soient convaincus mais
oui ce qui serait bien c'est qu'il vous
croit mais il n'y arrive pas mais qu'est
ce que vous en savez pas ce que je vois
bien ce que disent par exemple les
sondes à l'aller 101 ch dans les
sondages ils disent que ségolène royal
est à 51% et sarkozy à 49 bien c'est la
même chose 51/49 vous savez là tu vois
ça c'est la police mais oui 21 49 abri
l'adolescent dans un sondage 51 49 51 49
vous croyez que ça fait par contre quand
on provoque encore quand on présente les
chipmunks rouler ça mais moi je suis
d'accord ségolène royal est une très
bonne candidate
on n'est pas là pour remplir jeunesse ou
à ce mois ci on parle de quoi mais
pourquoi mais il attend alors vous
voulez interdire ou j'entends les ce qui
leur palais qui leur plaît pas le
résultat mais oui je sois la morale vous
la fête à tout le monde aux chaufferies
passera je vous dis que je suis jeune et
que vous montez ça s'appelle pas faire
l'amour à l'appel d'offre à prix ferme
avec voir ça citoyens non ça s'appelle
du faget rien n'à gagne alors si je dis
farm attaqué mois aubin moi je suis pas
responsable du ministère de l'intérieur
voilà mais moi tout ce que j'ai dit je
ne le retire pas tout ce que j'ai dit
rires et ej moi je vous ai expliqué paul
pouvez vous n'avez pas dangereux
commencé là brevets alors je vais vous
savez ce que vous devriez faire tirer un
mais deux vrilles à la table et monsieur
bauer oui à qui appelait chargé de jeu
connaît en plus que ce que vous lui
dirais que c'est un tricheur et menteur
parce que c'est l'été de ces
statistiques
et comme en plus je vous dis c'est pas
mes amis politiques au moins peut-être
lui vous le croirez sans problème si je
dis femme quelqu'un et il ya d'ailleurs
aussi je voulais vous de parler d' il ya
un rapport de
de l'igpn par les voilà qui qui lui dit
que tous ces chiffres sont il ya une
différence avec les haguenoviens bien au
sénat et gpl c'est quand même pas
n'importe quoi alors là donc la police
ne ment pas là donc là non parce que si
tu n'as l'audit interne c'est en savoir
exactement dans quel état se découvre
que la jolie mais il se trouve que ce
rapport donc n'a jamais été publié et
dans un coffre
alors moi j'aimerais bien le voir ce
rapport pour paris pourquoi pas mais
j'ai fait mature pourquoi pas mais il
est déjà il a literary ministre de
l'inde étaient payés quand même par
l'état les bérets c'est à dire nous
c'est à dire qu'on a payé pour quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas le droit de lire
c'est quand même fort mais attendez ça
prouve en tout cas une chose
contrairement à ce que vous disiez c'est
que quand il ya des anomalies
statistiques on fait une enquête
n'importe quoi mais comment n'importe
quoi maintenant c'est ce que vous avez
vu combien vous facilite il ya un moment
donné c'est vrai que j'ai encore des
progrès à faire sur jaguar est sûre si
vous avez pour la politique mais non
mais pas du tout mais oui moi contacts
et échanges tendus mais je demande n'a
pas du tout quand on ne suffit pas de
dire d'eau gens avec lesquels vous
n'êtes pas d'accord que ce sont des
tricheurs ne suffit pas pour avoir alors
si j'étais alors pour conclure c'est la
conclusion j'ai diffamé
si j'ai diffamé si j'aime je ne suis pas
la victime
si j'ai dit tout ce que j'ai dit soir je
ne le retire par mois je vous donc si
j'ai diffamé
oui que les jeunes que le les personnes
donc si j'aime ce jeu mythique qui
m'attaquent
et ce rapport de l'igpn qui est dans un
coffre-fort on aimerait bien le voir
oui mais c'est ce rapport d'ailleurs des
extraits ont été publiés mais c'est
parfaitement vrai j'ai pris le minimum
d'erreurs je vous dis que c'est pas si
pourtant très clair je vous dis que
quand il y à des anomalies qui sont
signalés y compris par des gens comme
vous on fait une enquête et l'igpn fait
une enquête
oui bien c'est pas une enquête il
faudrait un changement de gouvernement
on peut toujours rêver alors justement
le résultat du sondage là il le vit
comment nicolas sarkozy d'inviter points
séparent par ségolène royal
en tous les cas je suis bien d'abord dit
pas que c'est bien mais attendez vous
rendez compte
s'il part villepin était à 6 berrouet
tassin je peux donc nicolas sarkozy doit
être très content il est à 30 vous et je
peux vous dire que vous vous rendez
compte de ce qui vient de se passer on
vient d'avoir le cpe il y avait deux
millions de personnes dans la rue ouais
hein
et à l'issue
de ça ségolène royal ne fait que 51
contre 49 contre le candidat de la
droite
ça va pas si mal à l'issue d'une crise
pareille inquiété quand même assez
inquiétant très bon on jeudi 51/49 c'est
la même chose ça vous fait frémir
mais vous savez que dans les sondages la
marge d'erreur est de 2 %
ouais à au moins 2 2% donc entre 51 et
effectivement c'est tapant de près mais
53 40 équipes face on verra ça le jour
de l'élection
on verra ça le jour de l'élection alors
oui moi mais je vais vous dire moi je
suis ravi que ce soit ségolène royal qui
soit en tête plutôt que d'autres
candidats socialistes parce que elle a
un discours qui me convient et qui n'est
plus le discours gauchiste qu'on
entendait autrefois c'est suivre un
chemin beaucoup plus moderne c'est vrai
c'est séculariste mais elle se déclare
admiratrice de tony blair franchement
pour mon pays si la gauche doit gagner
les élections sont peut arriver moi je
fais pas le faro c'est la gauche doit
gagner les élections je souhaite que ce
soit plutôt une gauche blairiste vrai
que une gauche allié avec le parti
communiste et tous les registres de
france qui font un peu exception et
tache dans le paysage européen donc
patrick sarkozy est content parce que
les conneries de villepin s'ils ont rien
coûté finalement pourquoi vous dites ça
non bien sûr ça nous a pénalisés banon
la banque mondiale 7,6 mari voilà je
vous dis bien sûr ça voulait dire que le
potentiel de la droite devait être
beaucoup plus important qu'il n'est pour
que nous fassions quand même 49 après un
événement pareil il faut peut-être aussi
le talent de sarkozy pour arriver à ça
ouais et ses résultats comme les eaux
l'intérieur qui sont appréciées par la
fin résultat six engins mais son bilan
est mauvais rappelait il faut le répéter
encore voilà il faudrait maintenant mais
ce qui serait bien aussi c'est que la
presse s'en mêle un petit peu et puis
les hommes politiques d'opposition s'en
mêle l'annoncé par un complot la preuve
semble un petit peu et que ce soit pas
moi qu'ils soient obligés de dire voilà
ce qui se fait en forme il est le seul à
s'y coller vous rendez compte
non je suis pas le seul son frère aîné
et sauf bah on s'arrête on s'arrête et
me rendre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
patrick mettions à moi le ministère de
la parole c'est julia l'archipel
japonais
[Musique]
mais alors un dry qu'on vous a pas
entendu pendant ce débat sur sarkozy
écoutez c'était déjà assez chaud comme
ça et j'avais envie de leur dire arrêtez
on est tous des frères est peut-être pas
dans les commissaires allaient a quand
même à moi je veux bien être le frère de
quelqu'un d'honnête aura qu'à écouter ce
qu'on va faire vous allez partir tous
les deux vous allez vous serez spears
était une bonne idée vous avez l'eau
jaillit figurants cogis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]